así salían las fuerzas de paz lideradas
por rusia y así llegaban a kazajistán
tras la petición del presidente toka
jeff el objetivo devolver la estabilidad
a la mayor economía de asia central país
productor de metales petróleo y gas y un
gran aliado de moscú y donde vladimir
putin no quiere perder influencia desde
la casa blanca ayudan del movimiento
tenemos preguntas sobre la naturaleza de
esta petición y si es una legítima
invitación o no no sabemos en este punto
las autoridades informaron de decenas de
muertos incluyendo 18 oficiales dos de
ellos decapitados así como más de 2.000
detenidos estas imágenes muestran como
ésta almaty la ciudad más poblada de
kazajistán los manifestantes iniciaron
sus protestas contra la subida del
precio del gas el cual se dobló en un
año ahora sus reclamos van más allá en
un país rico en recursos pero de
población pobre desde el gobierno culpan
a la injerencia extranjera y acusan a
los manifestantes de terroristas
internamente surgen voces que quieren
capitalizar el descontento ya no era un
presidente sino una pública
parlamentaria siempre digo que liderar
el gobierno temporal que derrocara a
nursultán nasarbayev durante seis meses
los manifestantes culpan principalmente
a nazarbáyev el último jefe del partido
comunista en liderar un país ex
soviético fue presidente desde 1991 y
hasta 2019 pese a dejar el cargo ha
mantenido su influencia como líder de la
nación y dando su nombre a la capital
insultan hasta ahora el actual
presidente toca para tratar de alejarse
destituyéndolo como líder del consejo de
seguridad me ayuda a que sin embargo no
ha servido para calmar las calles